muchos políticos y medios de
comunicación de gran éxito comparten una
premisa no permitir nunca a bajo ningún
concepto y en ninguna circunstancia que
la verdad estropee un buen titular ya
sabéis es lo que me sirven ti uno se
conoce como el poder del clic y eso eso
es lo que casi siempre ocurre y cuando
se habla de pobreza de pobreza y de
otros muchos retos sociales desde el
cambio climático hasta la despoblación
rural no importa porque realmente no
importa mucho el tema ni tampoco cuál
sea la realidad si tuviéramos que
fijarnos únicamente de las consignas más
habituales que escuchamos por aquí y por
allá en la tele en boca de nuestros
políticos o mismamente en el whatsapp lo
de los nidos de whatsapp eso ya es cosa
de otro planeta pues podríamos llegar a
tener la sensación de que nuestro mundo
se está yendo a pique tenemos mejor
acceso a las noticias a la comunicación
que nunca y en los medios las malas
noticias son las que venden los
desastres y las tragedias no son algo
nuevo pero los móviles y las cámaras sí
lo son y esto hace que nos dé la
impresión de que esos horrores son más
frecuentes de lo que eran
johan norberg escritor e historiador
sueco
[Música]
pero amigos este vídeo no va de fitness
ni de nada por el estilo de eso
hablaremos en un evento el día 25 de
febrero en madrid por si os interesados
dejo la info en la descripción en esta
ocasión queremos poner sobre la mesa un
enfoque completamente diferente una
estrategia nueva para combatir la
pobreza y muchos de los retos sociales a
los que nos enfrentaremos durante las
próximas décadas
pero antes antes tenemos que dar las
gracias a nuestros amigos de mi crowd
micro auto es una empresa que da
microcréditos a mujeres emprendedoras de
regiones muy pobres en países como por
ejemplo o nicaragua perú o méxico es una
idea de la que luego hablaremos y que ya
os garantizo puede hacer volar por los
aires muchas de las ideas preconcebidas
que todos tenemos cuando hablamos sobre
cómo escapar de la pobreza soy alejandro
de león fundador de microsoft y en este
vídeo os vamos a hablar de
emprendimiento social
[Música]
amigos durante las últimas décadas hemos
visto como la pobreza en el mundo se ha
reducido casi tan rápido como lionel
mesi coleccionaba balones de oro
tan solo los últimos 25 años más de mil
millones de personas escaparon de la
extrema pobreza eso ha hecho que según
los últimos datos del banco mundial el
porcentaje de la humanidad que aún vive
en situación de extrema pobreza pasase
de casi el 40% de la población a poco
más del 8 todo en 25 años vale lo sé
puede que estos datos pues no cuadren
mucho con todo eso que nos cuentan de
que cada vez más pobres de que el
capitalismo salvaje está destruyendo la
humanidad de que los ricos se están
quedando con todos etcétera etcétera y
si puede también que sea una visión
menos trágica y menos excitante que una
historia de proletarios injusticias y
revoluciones pero amigos esa es la
realidad
[Música]
os lo hemos contado aquí en visual
política en algunos vídeos que os dejo
también en la descripción las cosas van
tan bien que por primera vez en toda la
historia de la humanidad la mayoría de
la población ya no es pobre pero ahora
viene un momento que estos sean mejores
números que la hoja de resultados de
apple no quiere decir ni que esté todo
bien ni que ya esté todo hecho para nada
es evidente que en el mundo aún hay
mucha muchísima pobreza cuanta pues
fijaos
que algo más del 8 por ciento de la
humanidad viva en la extrema pobreza
implica que más de 600 millones de
personas a día de hoy aún no tienen
garantizada ni siquiera una alimentación
básica y eso eso es simple y llanamente
algo terrible
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de
áfrica si en visual político os hemos
contado como algunos de los países del
continente han comenzado a despegar como
la pobreza se está reduciendo pero
houston tenemos un problema aunque el
porcentaje de pobreza extrema se ha
reducido el incremento tan grande de la
población que ha experimentado el
continente africano ha hecho que en
números absolutos la situación sea
exactamente la contraria
para que os hagáis una idea hoy hay 150
millones de africanos más en la pobreza
extrema que en 1990
[Música]
así que la pregunta es cómo diantres
podemos superar esta situación cómo
lograr erradicar la extrema pobreza del
mundo pues sabéis que justo aquí es
donde aparecen algunos de los grandes
errores que hemos cometido cosas que
siempre te han contado estrategias que
has dado por hecho y que sin embargo
puede que no sirvan para nada atentos
[Música]
el método que nunca funciona te hago una
pregunta cuántas veces has escuchado eso
de que la culpa de la pobreza es de los
países más ricos porque no gastan lo
suficiente en ayuda al tercer mundo
estoy seguro de que no ha sido ni una ni
dos ni tres sino un montón las veces que
has escuchado esta idea pero alguna vez
te has preguntado cuánto dinero gastan
en ayuda al tercer mundo los países
desarrollados
[Música]
pues amigos creo que os vais a
sorprender veréis en el año 1960 se creó
el llamado comité de ayuda al desarrollo
un organismo que forma a su vez parte de
la ocde también conocida como el club de
los países desarrollados pues bien este
comité de ayuda al desarrollo está
compuesto por estos 30 integrantes que
veis en pantalla
sabéis cuánto gastan cada año estos
países en ayuda al desarrollo alguna
apuesta pues agarrados a la silla porque
cada año estos países destinan a la
ayuda al desarrollo casi 150 mil
millones de dólares y si lo habéis
escuchado bien 150 mil millones 1,3
billones de dólares tan sólo en la
última década
[Música]
ahora
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
supone esta cifra la podemos comparar
con el plan de asistencia más famoso de
todos los tiempos el plan para la
reconstrucción europea popularmente
conocido como el plan marshall
el programa de ayudas que eeuu puso en
marcha tras la segunda guerra mundial
para apoyar la reconstrucción de europa
pues bien sabéis cuánto dinero puso
sobre la mesa de eeuu para financiar ese
programa pues ojo en dólares de hoy
aproximadamente 100 mil millones de
dólares insisto de dólares de hoy
actualizados
es decir cada año los países más ricos
destinan 15 veces todo el plan marshall
en ayuda a los países en vías de
desarrollo la región que más fondos
recibe con mucha diferencia es el áfrica
sub-sahariana y sabéis que esta ayuda no
ha tenido nada que ver con el incipiente
desarrollo que algunos países están
logrando
fijaos por ejemplo en lo que dice esta
conocida economista africana atentos la
idea de que la ayuda puede aliviar la
pobreza sistemática es un mito la ayuda
es un desastre económico político y
humanitarios sin precedentes para la
mayor parte del mundo en desarrollo
dambisa moyo economista zambiana pero
por qué ocurre esto
pues veréis los gobiernos de los países
ricos y los organismos internacionales
como la onu o el banco mundial pueden
financiar la construcción de una escuela
de un pozo o de una depuradora y todo
eso está bien el problema es que no crea
actividad económica sostenible ni
tampoco capacita a los países para
gestionar administrar y financiar todas
esas infraestructuras en otras palabras
que cuando el dinero se termina el
dinero que por supuesto en muchos casos
termina en las cuentas corrientes de
todo tipo de sátrapas y dictadores pues
la aventura llega a su fin
no hay más empresas más comercio ni más
empleos que sean realmente competitivos
lo más que puede quedar es alguna
especie de escuela donde los profesores
quizás a duras penas sepan leer y así
pues no se puede
y todo esto por no hablar de la
competencia desleal que la cooperación
supone para muchas empresas locales o el
gasto que le genera por ejemplo
mantenimiento de infraestructuras
productivas a gobiernos que difícilmente
pueden hacerle frente a un desastre
precisamente por todo esto cada vez son
más los expertos que defienden que la
ayuda oficial al desarrollo pues no
sirve así que como veis no es un
problema de gastar mucho o de gastar
poco
[Música]
y eso no es todo además de toda la ayuda
gubernamental los países ricos también
envían cada año miles y miles decenas de
miles de millones a los países más
pobres a través de contribuciones que
los propios ciudadanos hacen a un montón
de ongs
y a ver no me malinterpretéis aquí eso
está muy bien muchas ongs hacen una
labor increíble necesaria imprescindible
para paliar situaciones que son
terribles
el problema es que bueno digamos que a
la hora de sacar permanentemente a gente
de la pobreza tienen los mismos
problemas que la ayuda gubernamental
simplemente ese no es su campo de
actuación
[Música]
y si lo pensamos un momento es lógico la
labor de las ongs es imprescindible para
prestar servicios médicos a ayudar en
caso de catástrofes garantizar la
educación de muchos niños detrás
etcétera pero todo ese trabajo hay que
complementarlo con otras iniciativas
para poder lograr que un país escape de
la pobreza en el caso de áfrica por
ejemplo se necesita no sólo ayuda sino
también empleos empleos y más empleos
ahora bien cómo conseguimos todos esos
empleos que hacen falta pues aquí amigos
la evidencia empírica es clara hace
falta capital capital capital dedicado a
elevar la productividad es decir
inversión empresas máquinas herramientas
tecnologías redes de comunicación
etcétera etcétera
los países ricos no son ricos porque si
son ricos porque tienen mucho más
capital trabajando para ellos pero claro
os hago una pregunta a ver quién creéis
que a estar dispuesto a soltar la pasta
a poner su dinero a invertir en
sociedades tan pobres o en países con
tantas carencias institucionales si no
hay mercado no hay infraestructuras no
hay trabajadores cualificados y ni
siquiera tejidos de gobierno pues no
invierte y eso es lo que se conoce como
la trampa de la pobreza y es lo que
impide que muchas sociedades salgan
adelante es una especie de círculo
vicioso y queridos amigos de visual
político es justo aquí donde surge una
actividad que puede cambiarlo todo
[Música]
el emprendimiento social
has escuchado alguna vez hablar de el
emprendimiento social pues amigos aquí
puede estar una de las claves para
derrotar a la pobreza
pero a qué nos referimos exactamente
cuando hablamos de emprendimiento social
para saberlo hemos tenido la oportunidad
de hablar con alejandro de león
alejandro exactamente qué es una empresa
social
para mí una empresa social sería una
empresa que intenta beneficiar a sus
stakeholders
es decir stakeholder es una palabra
significa a todos los agentes que tienes
alrededor a tus proveedores a tus
clientes a tus socios a tus empleados y
una empresa tradicional es la que
beneficia sólo a los siervos de los
accionistas entonces yo una empresa
social la concibo como una empresa que
tiene unas bases muy sólidas que es
capaz de beneficiar a todo su entorno y
a partir de ahí crecer todo lo que pueda
y si se hiciera una definición en un
tuit diría una empresa social es una
empresa que no necesita una fundación
luego que ya su leitmotiv es
suficientemente bueno como para no tener
que tener una fundación que haga cosas
sociales aparejadas
es decir hablamos de una empresa donde
la rentabilidad se complementa con otros
objetivos sociales los beneficios por sí
mismos no son la única meta
[Música]
aunque eso sí a diferencia de las ongs
aquí la rentabilidad es algo fundamental
y la verdad es que tiene todo el sentido
del mundo
[Música]
para nosotros es importante la
rentabilidad porque al final va a haber
una rentabilidad siempre en un producto
u otro aunque sea cíclico no sea es
decir la bolsa siempre va a tener cierta
rentabilidad la renta fija cierta
rentabilidad del inmobiliario es de
rentabilidad por decir 3 de los activos
más
históricamente más entonces como esa
rentabilidad va a estar siempre lo que
se llama el benchmark no es el nivel de
mercado siempre va a estar ahí por
ejemplo la bolsa de américa nada un 7%
histórico hay dos maneras o sea está
competir con esta alternativa con el
mercado a competir cara a cara y decir
yo voy a dar más de un 7 porque todas da
un 7 histórico y yo voy a ser mejor que
tú en términos de rentabilidad o
competir en términos de compasión es
decir yo te voy a repartir un 1 por
ciento un dos por ciento de rentabilidad
o un cero pero yo voy a ayudar a la
gente entonces cada uno tiene que elegir
su alternativa nosotros el micro que
hemos elegido la alternativa de competir
cara a cara con el mercado de valores
porque porque creemos que de esta manera
uno si te quieres sentar con los grandes
capitales si quieres que te inviertan no
te van a invertir por compasión la
compasión va a ayudar pero tiene que ser
un plus pero te tienen que tienen que
invertir si son grandes cantidades no le
puedes pedir a alguien que tiene mil
millones por poner un ejemplo no le
puedes pedir no mira te vas a renunciar
a un 5% de rentabilidad porque son 50
millones de euros no seas una barbaridad
entonces si quieres traer los grandes
capitales al impacto social
a los países más desfavorecidos y más
vulnerables tienes que competir cara a
cara con el mercado de valores así es
como lo vemos nosotros
[Música]
capitales y competitividad es que casi
parece de cajón y si vale puede que te
suenen como términos muy económicos pero
qué demonios seamos serios si esto va
realmente de sacar a gente de la pobreza
hay que lograr integrarlos en el sistema
económico no buscar dejarle fuera
el caso es que hay empresas sociales de
todos los tipos y de todos los colores
desde las que se centran en crear
trabajos para personas con alguna
minusvalía hasta las que luchan por
preservar el medio ambiente o también
las que luchan contra la pobreza como es
precisamente el caso de micro
pero como tenemos la fortuna de contar
con alejandro fundador y ceo de esta
empresa creo que lo mejor va a ser que
nos lo cuente el mismo alejandro que es
exactamente mi kraus
[Música]
bueno que es lo primero que tengo que
decir es que me crowd no es una no es
una idea que yo tuve un día en casa sino
es una necesidad de mercado y antes hice
banca empezando unas becas a unos niños
y un aprendizaje que tú ves que no
necesariamente todas las becas eran
positivas para ellos para los niños yo
hablé con las madres de estos niños de
caos que tenía y algunas madres me
decían que la beca le parecía bien y
otra vez decía que la había aceptado
pero que le había hecho una faena porque
el niño cuando cuando digo niño puede
ser un adolescente pues le ayudaba a
ingresar más en el mes mes a mes y que
era una faena que se hubiera ido la
universidad no antes al final ahí
temblaron todos mis todos mis prejuicios
343 de estas 50 madres me pidieron
microcréditos entonces y una necesidad
muy grande de de prestar de meter
crédito en la comunidad vale porque
cuando digo que me pidieron
microcréditos no lo necesariamente lo
verbalizaron como quiere un microcrédito
sino una me decía que una vaca y otra me
decía mi sueño se emprende entonces
empecé con 10 el primer año allá por
2013 yo solo y sin tener pensado que
quería montar una empresa
siguiente 20 y al tercer año de repente
me di con 85 créditos por toda la magia
el interés compuesto que hablaba
itzstein probablemente sea apócrifo a la
frase pero es muy buena no la de la
fuerza del interés compuesto de repente
me di con 85 con la necesidad de crear
una empresa 3 esa es la gran ventaja y
cuando creas una empresa de una
necesidad real y vamos a decir acuciante
pues al final tienes mucho solucionado
entonces yo empecé a prestar el primer
año dimos 500 el segundo vimos 1500 y el
año pasado llegamos a cuatro mil
créditos que bueno en total hemos
ayudado como unas tres mil señoras y al
final el proceso ha sido de mucha
repetición también es a las mismas
señoras cancelaban su primer crédito y
nos daba en el segundo crédito
[Música]
por el lado del inversor pues nosotros
intentamos pues ahora el fondo que
estamos lanzando va a dar entre un 525 y
un 9 de rentabilidad y las carteras que
tenemos de inversores a través de la web
pues han dado como un 6.90 al final del
año pasado entonces al final obviamente
como como hemos comentado esto es
competitivo con el mercado de valores o
es lo primero que queremos de cimientos
al inversor lo primero que le damos es
rentabilidad económica y el valor
añadido de nuestro producto es cada vez
está ayudando a un montón de mujeres
porque con una cartera por ejemplo de
cien mil euros se ayuda a final de año a
más de doscientas mujeres el impacto es
gigantesco
[Música]
por el lado de la mujer que es la que
recibe el crédito digamos que las
métricas que nosotros manejamos es para
mí la más importante es que generamos
245 puestos de trabajo por cada crédito
que concedemos esto quiere decir que
seguimos 25 mil créditos históricamente
habremos generado más de 12 mil puestos
de trabajo en los objetivos del fondo
que estamos lanzando ahora son 40 mil
mujeres como objetivo y 100 y más de 100
mil puestos de trabajo sea el impacto va
a ser brutal en estas comunidades pero
no sólo esto sino que las mujeres más
del 90% invierten en la educación de sus
hijos más del 90 por ciento mejora en su
casa ponen un baño o una puerta una
ventana a que las casas son comunes e
van haciendo poco a poco el 66 por
ciento ahorran que súper importante y
estamos empezando a comercializar
productos de ahorro para ellas y micro
seguros no sea que ellas contraten sus
micros seguros por si el negocio es
normal porque se enferman para que de
por si se mueren incluso para que los
niños puedan seguir estudiando
y estas son pocas las métricas que
manejamos
también el caso que más me ha impactado
y que mezcla muy bien lo que yo creo que
va a ser el mundo y la ventaja que tiene
la tecnología y la ventaja que tenemos
la generación de ahora versus una
generación de hace 10 años es el
whatsapp como muchas de ellas han dicho
el whatsapp ha sido una bendición para
ellos el 90% de nuestras clientas usan
whatsapp muchas de ellas por motivos
comerciales este es un ejemplo que me
encanta y que creo que explica muy bien
el mundo en que vivimos que es una mujer
que todos los días hace un vestido o
cada dos piezas un vestido o lo que
tarde no antes según termina el vestido
se lo envía a todos sus contactos de
whatsapp y el primero que diga que lo
quiere y vaya lo compra
es como una especie de plataforma tipo
grupo no cualquier plataforma de
descuentos pero en base de la pirámide
en una zona rural en perú pues ella sube
todos los días este vestido y hace una
especie de
sí desde que el primero llegue se queda
con el vestido entonces ella nos decía
que su gran aprendizaje sí con la
tecnología todos somos conscientes de
que ella cada día tiene más contactos en
la agenda y por tanto cada día le
compraban el vestido más rápido pero
además no solo este ejemplo sino que
tenemos ejemplos de mujeres que envían
productos alimenticios y los envían
también con un motorista y se los piden
por whatsapp o por redes sociales
entonces al final la tecnología te
permite una cosa que con una tarifa
plana con un coste digamos fijo
consigues varia habilitar absolutamente
tus ingresos entonces digamos que las
economías de escala y las bondades de
los de controlar los medios de
producción han dejado de ser bondades
sólo de unos para ser bondades de todos
y a mí no parece un cambio fundamental
[Música]
fijaos hay una frase que tanto alejandro
como isabel como todo el equipo de micro
utilizan casi como un lema y que os doy
mi palabra a mí me encanta algo así como
no les des el pez pero tampoco intentes
enseñarle a pescar eso ya lo saben hacer
lo que necesitan es financiación para
comprar sus propias cañas de pescar
[Música]
amigos espero que toda esta historia se
esté resultando igual de fascinante que
a mí esta idea de poder ganar dinero al
tiempo que se ayuda a las personas que
más problemas tienen me parece increíble
os dejamos en la descripción un par de
enlaces para que podáis conocer este
proyecto con más profundidad
y ojo porque no es ninguna tontería a
algunas de estas actividades puede ser
tan rentable para los inversores como la
propia bolsa norteamericana
[Música]
de hecho los estudios existentes hablan
de rentabilidades en el entorno del 7%
anual es decir al mismo nivel que la
rentabilidad histórica de la bolsa en
los estados unidos
en otras palabras obtienes beneficios y
al mismo tiempo ayudas a un montón de
personas a escapar de la pobreza
personas como nos decía alejandro que a
su vez contratan y ayudan a otras
personas y así de la trampa de la
pobreza se pasa a la espiral del
crecimiento suena bien verdad
amigos esta es la nueva corriente que
puede cambiar el mundo y lograr que la
pobreza sea cosa de museos y ojo lo
mismo puede suceder con otros muchos
problemas sociales en fin muchas gracias
a todo el equipo de mi crowd por su
apoyo para poder preparar este vídeo y
ya sabes si te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte a visual político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]